so there's a lot of controversy over
people wanting certain pronouns to be
used for them okay people refusing my
compromises I'll you know when people
like Jordan Peterson say you can't force
me to speak a certain way right my
answer is I agree but so I don't single
single you out I will call literally
every one floor bow as there as a
general pronoun yeah it's not a harsh
word no K sounds no T's yeah it's very
mu
so would that be in replace of like they
them Caesar Zim Zorba is IRA phone hey
floor Bo floor Bo says that floor Bo
self you know floor Bo says that he that
floor Bo loves floor Bo self hmm he said
that he loves himself but you know you
can't say he so if someone comes to me
and says you must use my pronouns I'll
be like oh we're stopping where's that
we're in floor mode floor boma and but
here's the thing it's not meant to be
disrespectful it's meant to assert my
autonomy as an individual can speak
mm-hmm and to not single you out by
using a new org with no harsh sounds so
everyone can now be a floor well in
Sweden in Sweden they actually have
there's his hers and and non his and
hers and it's like it's actually like
hit they like there's like her or his
and then it's that's basically but it's
not that because that to me is confusing
for the general public to like try to
change their it's not an actually
there's not right it's not it's not one
they is not one you know they is
multiple so it's sometimes they can be
one right and and I can yeah sometimes
but they're trying to do it like all the
time but in in that language they
actually have a word that applies to
anyone that isn't his or hers and that's
awesome like why can't it always been
that way or is that one of those new
freaky so no I don't I don't think it's
always been that way or maybe it has I I
don't know for certain but it's awesome
like why can't we just come up with
something that's similar floor bow boom
no floor bow isn't his or hers in that
same sense the floor bows like hey there
and there's is as I was just saying
whose head is that more thing for the
most for the public I feel because it's
referring to multiple people we're
always right today and them as multiple
people not one person
if this person is uncertain I'd say it's
there's this there's no I mean I get it
I don't understand I'm not confused in
the manner I'm just saying I feel like
most most people I've talked to they say
it's because it's confusing that it's
multix I think it's bidet is it Laurel
it's like Bickley plural right like why
couldn't we just come up with a new like
Freight like line a new word yes a new
word that would apply to anyone that
doesn't work that way like it should we
could we can come up it's it's a weird
argument all those floor bow feels like
you're just kind of like poking fun at
like I don't really care well I didn't
want to use a ke T or P sound because
those are harsh noises right I give it o
is a very well flow it should start with
an H what his hers
no but Z&Z answer it would be offensive
to them they're gonna say that's not
fair
Xian's are the answer yes he answers are
non-binary pronouns there's literally
okay
over a hundred documented pronouns that
have been made up so you have to over a
hundred are you serious yeah Wow I'm not
kidding you can tumblr tumblr is a list
like a thousand Wow because they're
literally making them up so my issue was
if you say a kano is a teen oiz upon
knows yeah these are harsh sounds yeah
so I want we want to avoid that make
something flow flow herb oh it's very
it's two syllables it's very rolls off
the tongue not harsh and it and it
avoids any kind of grammatical syntax or
anything so no one can accuse of any
kind of listen man you can't tell me the
words I use this is the word for
everybody we're done and then you know
you want to try and demand that I have
to call you Zee Orser well no I call
everyone the same thing I'm not singling
you out
zere's er actually sounds pretty like it
kind of makes sense his or her Zee Orser
it's kind of all I mean it's two
different things the problem is it's
still a masculine and feminine oh but in
English we choose what we want to say to
convey an idea you're right the thing
about Z's are and these are the pronouns
is they're coming to you and saying you
have to call me this not everybody not
everybody some people lost feels like a
whole conversation we're getting into it
oh yeah yeah yeah they're part of things
it's nuts I mean the a guy lost his job
over this I heard about that yeah and
and and and the challenge here I think
with that story was that the guy was an
employee of the government run and he
was instructed to treat you know patrons
essentially a certain way mm-hmm if you
work for Starbucks and you call a
customer or something they don't to be
called and you keep doing it mm-hmm
they're gonna fire you yeah and it's not
discrimination so it's it's it's a tough
line but anyway
hence what words should I use you know
you know they mean like no matter what
I'd say if they're gonna make up words
I'm gonna make up word and I was I was
careful about how I navigate it what
this word would be okay and I think so
you came up with floor above yourself
yeah all right so I I've actually seen
multiple people talking about it
actually boom there you go
so I actually have worked with people in
marketing sales nonprofit fundraising
kind of stuff we talked about branding
names good names versus bad names okay
and the harsh noises yeah how bad you
want to make sure it's very easy to say
flows simple and literally flow like
that's why I went for the FL Oh mm-hmm
and I thought floor bow was like in my
mind I imagine a puffy happy cloud sayin
I see that as and I'm like this is a non
offensive respectful way to address
everybody without being told what I have
to say I've chosen to say it but if
someone wants to get offended well
that's too bad you don't own the world
it's not your world you know I think
that's the issue everyone everyone does
think that that is it a millennial thing
kind of feels like it it's a
participation I think it's a society
it's a patient Roby kind of thing it's
all of these different things it's an
accumulation of all the different
choices the society as a whole has made
that's led us here
it's it's snow out there I can't just be
like it's this it's like all these
different bubbles of things that are
happening that are just like all coming
down at once you know it's but but the
issue with this is that there are laws
being enacted because of it and so quite
literally in I think most blue states
you have to use the words demanded by
the individual like you have to legally
yes well it's it's in public
accommodation so if you are saying
Burger King and one day an employee
comes to you and says from now on my
name is Vlasov Ron okay my pronouns are
floor bo floor bus and floor bo self you
have to say those words if you don't you
can be fined for a violation of civil
rights and so it's gotten to this
extreme and there's thousands of
different ones infinite well you're
saying Wikipedia has thousands tumblr
tumblr has but it's it's like documented
New York City's 31 genders but you just
told me that's not how the English
language works we don't make good stuff
you're right it doesn't work that way
but people are doing it they're doing it
and they're exploiting the law to gain
political power and the law and and it's
like yeah you know what I don't know if
it's because the courts haven't caught
up yet it's typically how it plays out
if you know this guy who got fired
because he refused to address a trans
person by female pronouns okay that's
more specific because male and female
are things male and female pronouns
exist
yeah and he said I refused and they said
you're an employee not a protester so it
wasn't it wasn't even in the gray area
not like it was they wanted a white guy
or girl yeah there was a trans woman who
want to change women her a female now
she and and the guy said I refused
because it goes against my beliefs in
gender identity etc that's kind of most
of them and the argument from the judge
was you're a government employee who was
given the option to use a proper name
instead of a pronoun right my
understanding I guess is that he didn't
want to use a female name for a
biological male and that's his belief
system right the issue here I think is
that he was an employee it doesn't seem
like that big of a deal like the
customer deal dude the customer's always
right like I got under even it and the
customer in this sense wasn't even being
ridiculous it was a simple I mean if it
was a trans woman it's it's not like
it's not like it's some random word like
floor bow that you'd have to get used to
like introducing right to your mind to
like remember to say if it's a trans
woman it's a trans woman it's like all
right it's a girl
it's her she named her Samantha whatever
you're right I agree I'll call anybody
whatever they want to be called right
yeah exactly in in in in this instance
it's someone saying you can't tell me
what to say I can call you whatever I
want now listen listen what kind of a
teacher is that no the problem is he's
an employee that's the problem and but
he was he a teacher though professor he
was a professor what professors and
should push back on students 100% yeah
in certain certain ways but like what's
what's the big deal he was like he was
he was choosing to make a stand yeah for
some like why why now what what is the
reason because you've got a bunch of
people demanding other people bend the
knee and to do as they're told and and
flip like how the system's typically
worked do you think that this guy
probably had history with this person
and now knew that they were kind of like
that like wanting to like just either
mind the no I think it already I think
it's a guy who someone came to him and
said I want you to call me this and he
says I'll call you what I feel like
calling you you can't tell me what to
say it says here your name's Sam well
Sam is well either way alright it says
says your name is jonathon that's a
pretty manly name right and then they
say call me Sarah like my name is Sarah
I'm calling you mr. Smith or John pick
one no you call me this or I'll report
you I can take your job and got fired so
he sued here's the thing it feels like
there's too many details I don't know I
just pretty messed I'll tell you why you
lost if you're an employee and your boss
says we have customers customers the way
they want to be so so his he worked for
the government listener buzz right that
ridiculous
that was the organ from the courts
there's a big difference if you were a
private citizen mm-hmm at a private in a
private company or something and tried
you know making a stand but you work for
a company you were told here's what we
want you how we want you to handle
essentially the customers and he said no
okay you're fired
yeah okay that's not really surprising
and the argument I guess was that was it
was it was a public university so the
government was doing it yeah and they
said it doesn't work that way and they
and like it's tough but I kind of agree
with the judge in this case that he was
fired because he was basically treating
an employee I'm treating customers in a
certain way but I understand the
sentiment and I agree like you can't
tell me what to call you if I look I can
call you you know four eyes if I want I
bother you you could write me but
whatever
don't be rude people have called me that
before and it's like I just mark those
people as people I don't associate with
anymore I don't try to give him I mean
late you see what people respect that
it's like if you have a problem just
okay I'm out I'll do my thing yeah but
we have a lot of people who are now
coming up being like no I refuse instead
of getting mad that you're saying
something they said it was unsafe he was
violent they were warning all their the
students to avoid the class they like
take it don't go see the sonic movie is
theirs homophobic slurs everywhere but
yes I know exactly the same exact thing
so you end up with situations like this
where this guy says I refuse to back
down because it's getting out of hand
yeah and then he ends up losing his job
and thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we're live
Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and
if you want to catch the full recorded
podcast which doesn't appear in these
clips make sure you join by clicking the
button down below become a member and
then go to the community tab of this
YouTube channel and you can see all of
our full episodes don't forget to Like
share and subscribe if you want to get
more clips like this thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all in the next
show
you